foreign
Indianapolis hey Kyle welcome to the
Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call today
sure what's up
um so essentially uh I'm 19 years old
and two years ago
my dad pretty much put himself in a
position where he drank himself to I
don't know if you guys have heard the
term white brain
but it's pretty much a vitamin
deficiency and uh
it causes pretty much permanent
short-term memory loss
so now that's been going for two years
and
were there was a conservatorship and a
guardianship but
we're trying to switch that and we're
not really sure what to do with it
who's we
uh the the whole family I have two
siblings and then PS3 brothers and then
my mom is divorced
okay so she has anything to do with him
she's divorced right
right and so who's got the
conservatorship his brothers
um no it's actually my older brother but
he is like the most irresponsible person
there is so
um my mom pretty much
helps him do it all and in fact that
really helps he just she just does it
for him
um which we trust our mom but that's
like you said divorce not really
would your brother
are you are you do you want it do you
want conservatorship do you want to take
the lead on some of these decisions are
you just frustrated by the whole mess
well
I ideally it would be either ideally
it's me because I mean quite frankly I
don't want to tune my own horn but
between his brothers and my siblings I'm
probably the most responsible but I just
and I feel like I'm 19 I'm trying to
start a career in real estate
yeah right I don't know how much
responsibility it is so a lot a ton yeah
is your dad going to need long-term care
is he able to care for himself in a new
capacity
he's an assisted living right now and I
mean
I don't know how much longer he has
quite frankly because he pretty much
smoke and drank his lungs and liver away
and now he's gained a ton of weight so
I just don't know how long of a
path this is
okay so if assisted living is only 48.
if Assisting Living is caring for his
daily needs
what will the conservator actually be
doing
um there's some paperwork that needs
updated yearly and then
if he needs to move facilities or if
from my understanding if he does pass
away or get close to passing away they
ultimately hold that
um
the responsibility of what happens next
and whatnot so
I can't
um Kyle I can't tell if you are asking
us a question or if you are
wrestling with what about the
conservatorship or if you are just
simply wrestling with
that the unfairness that you should have
to do this yeah that gnarly Paradox
between I love my dad and I want to take
care of him and I can't believe that I'm
in this position
well yeah and that's kind of
the last part of it is that
I think as a family as a whole we all
kind of feel like even if we all were
responsible and we're able to do it or
kind of just mad at them like
um whatever our burden that's fair both
and it is what it is yeah
yeah
I hate that for you I guess and then the
last option would be able to give that
responsibility to the state but
none of us really wants to do that but
at the same time it's been my experience
that if if you're making the choice to
not
um
if you're making the choice to not give
him over to the state then you're making
a choice to be a member of his a part of
his life
and if you're choosing to be a part of
those flashes of anger and frustration
that's part of the grieving process
that's normal that's I miss my dad you
and I can't believe he heard himself
like this because his actions now are
going to Ripple through his family for
Generations that's all real and
every moment you choose to dwell on what
happened in the past versus what we got
to deal with what's happening right now
and then what can we make of this and
what happens next in my career in my
life and my education too
is a choice to be miserable in the
present I don't want that for you
you get what I'm saying so if you turn
him over the state you you dust your
hands off and you walk away okay
if you choose to keep him and every day
you wake up and you're pissed off at him
you are choosing
to have the most miserable road ahead
right yeah so the the the only way it
would make sense
to move forward I think I'm hearing uh
if you move forward regardless of why
but you have got to commit to
this whole situation not taking up all
of the real estate in your brain
because otherwise you're going to spend
all your time ruminating and dealing
with this and talking about what some
conversation you can't have with a guy
that's not there anymore and
so that involves two things one is it
involves I'm going to very much
compartmentalize this and it's going to
get ten percent seven percent of my
brain to actually cause the Assisted
Living to occur to a cause hospice to
occur later and to plan a funeral later
um and I and the other thing is I've got
to really get with my pastor and walk
through the process of forgiveness and
set this down so that it doesn't take up
all of your brain
if it takes up all of your brain it's it
is completely unfair to you and I would
I would turn if you cannot do that and I
don't know if I could have at 19 Kyle
but if you cannot if you cannot do that
then you need to also clear your brain
by letting someone else do it other than
you
you do not have a moral or ethical
responsibility to take this on at 19.
you have the option to do it but you do
not have the
the Mandate from scripture or Society
for a 19 year old to fix his dad who
drove it drunk himself into the point of
being an invalid and in fact legally
your brother has that responsibility
right now right now nope yeah your
brother has it legally but you don't
have the the
weight of you have to do this or you're
a bad guy
that's not there
so the only way you can move forward is
if you set enough of this aside that
you're that you still have more than
enough room to have a great life in your
brain and sometimes the best thing you
can give your dad is to take care of
yourself and to get about living your
life to